l a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovi diosono fa vj ed oggi dopo
torniamo a fare il fate risponde le
domande me le faccio inviare in direct e
le leggo direttamente dai direct di
instagram così senza mettere
sovraimpressione il commento così non
devo neanche evitare il video anna mi
scrive mio fratello cosimo di sei anni
ti chiede se ai 22 anni perché non hai
la barba per lo stesso motivo perché non
c'è la tua sorella cosima
quante ragazze hai avuto tre da quando
faccio youtube 3 prima di youtube 0 che
poi è vero prove come la tua ragazza
tipo deve essere una tipa non un tipo se
no non va bene
qual è il tuo attore preferito al pacino
corretto cantante preferito al bano
hai mai baciato un palo adesso sì e no
potevano che è la mia ex rompuy madonna
madre mi escono con riescono chiara mi
chiede quale è stata l'esperienza più
bella della tua vita prendo andare in
giappone si tornare in giappone dopo una
volta che c'ero già stato perché una
volta che ci va in giappone è talmente
bello che poi vuoi andarci ancora di più
di prima quando torni qui di tornare in
giappone martina che la fan page forse
con più follower mia tra l'altro che ha
pubblicato questa foto bellissima anche
se ogni volta che mi fate gli eviti io
non dormo la notte
perché fate anche se cose che potrebbero
essere un problema
quanto mi mancava le fa vi risponde
anche a me tesoro qual è la parte più
bella del tuo lavoro e quale quella
peggiore alla parte più bella e quando
ti arrivano stipendi o forse l'ho già
detto un po di volte la parte più bella
di quello che faccio e registrare i
video perché ovviamente quando registico
che fa i giochi non è che fai e sai cosa
la parte più rottura di palle e montare
i video perché montare video degli
stalli ritagliare e riguardare vive le
musiche il gip porca vacca e de vos e
non finisco all'orario di pranzo un
pranzo alle tre del pomeriggio
ovviamente quindi il giocare però se ti
trovassi un default sto aprendo perché
fa un caldo veste scusate intitolazione
detta 80 e funzionante come ti
comporteresti seguire si legali di kira
o lui
a seguire si gli ideali di kira luce
resti per altri scopi
girata è una bellissima domanda vi sono
interrogato molto spesso su questa cosa
dirà thai non so come userei il desktop
probabilmente lo usa se avessi fatto
l'università quale facoltà ti saresti
scritto non avrei fatto l'università ma
un'accademia per montaggio video quindi
avrei lavorato in quell'ambito di che
siccome vi ho spiegato prima quanto mi
tartassa le balle
anche lì avrei fatto una scelta della
madonna sono babbo naso con le scelte
scolastiche io questa me ne ha fatte 10
di domande grazie mille lean di sì farai
più horror game si di propositi per
questo 2018 tirare uno schiaffo a pietro
più forte
hai già in programma qualche vacanza per
quest'anno no ti manca il giappone e se
sì cosa maggiormente si mi manca stare
lontano da pietro un paese che non vedo
l'ora di visitare di nuovo giappone
faresti un viaggio con human safari sì
che tra l'altro la dei capelli messi
peggio dei miei il senso buono però lui
sei mai venuti in svizzera
no c'è una lingua che ti ispira e
vorresti imparare thailandese torneresti
tra i banchi di scuola
no carbonara che non ti alzi fida tavola
o del sushi
se mai dovessi dire sushi penso che
l'italia si rivolterebbe contro questo
video e mi direbbero tutti non sei degno
di essere nato in nella nostra patria
quindi diciamo carbonara leopolda il
primo ricordo che hai da bambino
allora un ricordo che ho da bambino sono
io che mi sfracello per terra perché
stavo giocando a calcio e sfregando il
ginocchio sulla sulla ghiaia mi sono
aperto il ginocchio mi è rimasta ancora
la cicatrice ai dei progetti che stai
portando avanti o che è intenzione di
iniziare o dei progetti che sto portando
avanti da un anno ma non vi posso dire
assolutamente una mazza se non vi fanno
un culo così qual è il regalo più bello
che una fan ti abbia mai fatto questa
domanda verrà fatta camilla che sa
perfettamente che il regalo più bello
che mi abbiano mai fatto il suo quindi
me l'ha fatta sicuramente perché voleva
che me lo facessi vedere e io lo faccio
vedere questo è in assoluto il regalo
più bello che mi hanno mai fatto
ci sono le medaglie di pokemon questo
coso lo tengo manco fosse un cimelio di
famiglia
grazie camilla grazie ancora per questo
per per le medaglie
così posso dire di essere andato in
palestra come sono simpatico come hai
fatto ad affrontare la maturità pregando
hai mai volato tre metri sopra il cielo
per l'eternità
una ricorrenza
[Musica]
va bene
dc la cosa più strana che ti è successo
da quando vivi da solo cosa fa una
persona un ragazzo quando va a vivere da
solo il problema ovviamente io non so
cucinare va bè questo sapete già tutti
no
ora che faccio ordinò del cibo da
internet no e tante volte mi capita
ovviamente di ordinare la pizza quando
ordinò la pizza ovviamente poi da taglio
con la forchetta il coltello è mio io so
un problema io non faccio attenzione
alle cose ok taglio la pizza forchetta e
coltello
lascio le posate dentro il cartone poi
siccome io faccio schifo essendo una
persona che vive da solo quindi non va
da buttare subito il cartone della pizza
lo lascio lì sul tavolo poi me ne
dimentico il giorno dopo lo vedo ancora
risulta vola ora di pranzo sono
costretto a spostarlo perché se no devo
magna sopra il cartone della pizza e non
è cosa allora lo prendo e lo butto
problema è che mi dimentico che ci sono
le posate dentro questa roba è andata
avanti per un po di mesi fino a che non
mi son ritrovato che ci avevo tipo un
coltello e due forchette dicevo ma fosse
uno che entra in casa mia mi ruba le
posate o c'è qualcosa che non va e non
capisco questa una delle robe più
paranormali che mi succedono da quando
vivo da sola almeno una volta ti
piacerebbe tornare ragazzino per
rivivere quei momenti d infanzia intendi
l'infanzia dove mia madre mi lanciava
alle ciabatte perché giocavo tanto i
videogiochi mentre adesso mi pagano per
farlo se sei mai andato a letto con
qualcuno
hai mai pensato che i tuoi genitori ti
abbiano adottato
spiega perché si è andato a vivere da
solo allora sono a togliere da solo
perché quando uno fa un video urla c'è
si sente quello che stai dicendo no e se
tu parli alla videocamera
se un po scemo io che sono una persona
molto introversa no per me fare un video
con delle persone che stanno in casa è
un problema cioè non riesco a registrare
se c'è qualcuno in casa infatti sta
porta grazie a dio isola al suono in
modo tale che se qualcuno fuori neanche
mi sente però prima nella casa dove
stavo prima c'erano i miei genitori e
non riuscivo a registrare sapendo che
loro mi stavano sentendo allora uno dice
fa vj non poteva mettere la porta
insonorizzante sì però non sapevo come
kraft arla marcello perché ancora non
hai trovato un vero lavoro car che con
questo sto più che bene anche se è finto
soggiorno youtube non dovesse più essere
per te quello che ora come ora cosa
faresti ps ho quasi vent'anni art la tua
casata di hogwarts sono grifondoro ma
perché mi hanno assegnato grifondoro è
scontato dirlo mi hanno assegnato così
che celava c'è ma quante domande mi
avete fatto ma ci sono un miliardo ti
fidanzi arresti con giulia penna wow che
sono mandano a mai fatta proprio mai
fatta nessuno lo giuro con quel no
1 perchè lei è fidanzata una parte
quello è una bella ragazza però non
conta quello solo nell'amore nell'amore
contano tante cose conta e lettere non
ci attende giulia funziona
avevi detto che conoscevi il tuo primo
iscritto in un video ma mi sembra che
non ci hai mai rivelato la sua identità
ma io ho 21 anni e grazie averlo
specificato io so chi è mio primo
iscritto
proprio il primo iscritto al canale lo
so però non so se voglio dirlo in questo
mito perché sono un click day two
abbastanza non adesso ve lo dirò però ve
lo dirò anche tali da tutto primo bacio
16 hai mai avuto una ragazza lesbica
sì e non sto scherzando c'era una
lesbica però era bis cioè le piacevano
sia le ragazze che i ragazzi è proprio
per questo che le piacevo io
fai una dedica ai tuoi haters
insultandoli per farci divertire no non
lo faccio perché tanto non esistono
neanche più.se continua a insultare ogni
tanto la mamma degli haters nei video è
solo perché
per abitudine ma era neanche più senso
hai mai fatto una cosa 3d per un video a
tracy con pietro e thomas se qualcuno fa
fuori tutti igino nei commenti commette
un genocidio
io direi che posso concludere quella
video di oggi fa vi risponde c'è in
realtà non ho mai risposto a così tante
domande ma perché mettere i commenti
c'è una volta rispondevo veramente a 4
barra cinque domande al massimo in un
video solo adesso non fatte tipo una
ventina malanga anche di più perché mi
andava di rispondere un bel po di roba
visto che non lo facevo da un po
comunque raga io spero che vi sia
piaciuto questo momento mi piace anche
vari soffrendo da nella iscrizione farò
sicuramente un altro fa vi risponde più
avanti
[Musica]